Voiceover:The relative
frequency table below
shows statistics from a
study about the relationship
between the amount of time a person spends
using a computer before bed
and the amount that a
person sleeps each night.
For computer use,
each participant was classified
as minimal, moderate, or extreme.
Let's look at the frequency table below.
Let's see.
That's the frequency table,
and let's see,
there's 3 categories of computer time,
just like they told us,
minimal, moderate, and extreme.
This is before they go to bed or at night.
Then they have the 3 categories
of how much they're sleeping,
5 or a few hours per night,
5 to 7 hours per night,
or 7 or more hours.
OK, so that's fair enough.
Let's see what they want us to do.
They tell us, "Suppose there
were 17 people in the study
"who are both in moderate computer users
"and got 5 to 7 hours of sleep."
Moderate, 5 to 7.
This category right over here,
there are 17 people in
this category over here.
Just to mark that, let me ...
I copy and pasted this
chart onto my scratch pad
so I can write on it.
This group, they're telling us this group,
and my pen is really acting up.
I don't understand what's going on.
This group right over
here, there are 17 people.
That group right over there is 17 people.
Now what are they asking us?
They're saying, "How
many people in the study
"were both extreme computer users
"and got 5 to 7 hours of sleep?
"Round to the nearest whole number."
So extreme and got 5 to 7.
I'll get my scratch pad out.
They are saying how many
people are in this bucket,
in this bucket right over here?
I think I have to replace
my pen tablet or something.
I don't know why it's getting
all splotchy like this.
How would we think about this?
There are 17 people in this group.
How many people are in this group?
They tell us that 17 is 34% of the row,
of the row total,
so I guess you could say 17 is 34.3%
of the moderate computer users,
or you could say that
17 is 30% of the people
who slept 5 to 7 hours each night,
or you could say 17 is 10%,
is 10% of the total number of people.
Let's just go with that.
We could figure out the
total number of people.
So 10%,
actually, let me write it this way.
So 10% of the total,
10% of total is going to be equal to 17,
or that the total,
just divide both sides by 10%
is equal to 17 divided by 10%,
which is the same thing as 17 over 0.1,
which, of course, is equal to 170.
The total is 170,
and they tell us that extreme,
extreme computer users represent ...
extreme computer users who
sleep 5 to 7 hours per night
represent 11.7%,
11.7% of the total.
So the answer to their question
of how many people were
extreme computer users
who sleep 5 to 7 hours per night,
it's 11.7% of 170.
Let's go back over here.
We actually have a little
calculator tool here.
It's 11.7%, which is 0.117,
times 170,
times 170 is,
and let me make sure that
you can see what I'm doing
by scrolling over a little bit,
times 170 is equal to 19.89.
If we're rounding to the nearest whole,
that's going to be 20 people,
20 people.
And then they are going
to ask us some questions.
They say, "Does the table show evidence
"of an association between
being a minimal computer user
"and getting 7 hours of sleep or more?"
Let's just look at the chart.
An association between being
a minimal computer user
and getting 7 hours of sleep or more.
It looks like minimal computer users,
these are the minimal computer users
who get 7 or more hours of sleep.
There's a couple of ways to read this.
You could say that 51%
of minimal computer users
get 7 or more hours of sleep.
You could say that of the people
who get 7 or more hours of sleep,
55% are minimal computer users.
And of course, this one just says
that minimal computer users who
get 7 or more hours of sleep
represent 18.3% of all of
the people who were surveyed.
Let's look at the choices.
Actually, before I even
look at the choices,
let's see if there is an association.
It does look like if you look at,
if you look at minimal computer users,
it looks like a small percentage,
only 16% get 5 or few hours.
A higher percentage gets 5 to 7 hours,
and 51%, the highest percentage,
gets 7 or more.
So it looks like for
minimal computer users,
it looks like the distribution
is definitely weighted
towards getting more sleep.
For example, if we look at
the extreme computer users,
it's the opposite trend.
It's 47% have 5 or few hours per night,
33% 5 to 7 hours,
and then only 19% get 7 or more.
It looks like the moderate
is someplace in between.
Just looking at this,
just looking at each of these rows,
it looks like there is a trend
where if you use a computer for less time,
you are more likely to have more sleep,
and likewise, if you use a computer more,
you're more likely to have less sleep.
Another way to think about it,
when you look at the people
who are getting 7 or more hours of sleep,
a majority of them,
a majority of them are
minimal computer users,
and there's 3 categories.
So for 55% to be minimal computer users
really does feel like the
minimal computer users
are more ...
they're definitely more
disproportionately representing
the people who are getting 7 ...
or disproportionally
represented in this category
of 7 or more hours of sleep.
You see that the extreme
computer users in this category,
they represent only 20% of this category.
So it does look like
there is an association
between minimal computer use
and getting 7 or more hours of sleep.
But let's look at the
actual choices they give us.
Does the table show
evidence of association
between a minimal computer user
and getting 7 hours of sleep or more?
Yes, because 35.1% are
extreme computer users,
and 29.1% of people are moderate.
I go with the yes, but this doesn't seem
to really back up the claim.
This is just giving us some random data
about the percentage that
are extreme computer users
or moderate computer users.
No ...
well ...
I explained why I go with yes,
that there does seem to be a trend,
and I don't even believe
what this statement is
because the total column percentages
are essentially equal.
We see that the total column ...
that the column percentages,
the column percentages are not equal
for the various,
for people who are getting
7 hours or more of sleep.
We see that right over here,
55, 25, 20,
so I won't go with that one either.
Yes, because 51% of minimal computer users
get 7 or more hours of sleep,
and only 33% of all computer users
get 7 or more hours.
Yeah.
I mean that seems pretty good.
51% of minimal computer users
get 7 or more hours of sleep,
and only 33% of all computer users
get 7 or more hours of sleep.
That looks like a pretty good explanation,
so I'll check that,
but let's just review all of them.
No.
Well, I already said I think it's yes,
but because the total
percentage of extreme users
who get 5 to 7 hours of sleep
is the same as the total percentage
of moderate computer users
who get 5 to 7 hours of sleep.
So that doesn't really meet,
it's not touching on the
point that we're looking for.
Yes, because 55% of people who get 75 ...
who get 7 or more hours
are minimal computer users,
and only 35% of all people
are minimal computer users.
Actually, I'll go with this as well.
Oh yeah, this is a multi-select here,
so I could select that one as well.
This one, we're looking at of the ...
so here, we looked at the percentage
of minimal computer users
who get 7 hours of sleep,
and we saw that percentage is higher
than for the whole population.
Here, we're looking at the people
who get 7 or more hours of sleep,
and we're saying 55% of them,
55% of them are minimal computer users
even though only 35% of all the people
are minimal computer users.
So I would go with both of these.
And so let us check our answer,
and we got it right.